[MUSIC]
Some of the biggest communication
challenges we face take place
interpersonally, giving feedback,
revealing personal information,
apologizing.
The key to addressing these tricky
communications issues is to connect and
foster mutually respectful relationships.
Yet many of us have never learned
how to initiate, build and
sustain these types of relationships.
Hello, I'm Matt Abrahams and
I teach Strategic Communication at
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
Welcome to Think Fast,
Talk Smart, The Podcast.
To learn more about
the importance of connection, and
how to foster deep personal relationships.
I am thrilled to be joined by
Carol Robin and David Bradford,
who both taught the wildly
popular GSB class,
interpersonal dynamics,
also known as touchy feely.
Together they have just
written the book Connect,
Building Exceptional Relationships
with Family, Friends and Colleagues.
Thank you, Carol and David for being here.
>> I like being here.
>> For having us.
>> First off, congrats on your book.
I really enjoyed reading it.
I assess the value of a book by how many
clear takeaways I can immediately put
into practice and by that measure
your book was a huge success.
Shall we get started?
>> Let's go.
>> Absolutely
>> All right, so, Carol,
in your book you and David talk
about exceptional relationships.
What does this mean and what advice do you
have to help people develop exceptional
relationships in business?
>> An exceptional relationship is one in
which both parties can feel be vulnerable
with each other and
more fully known by each other.
They can be honest with each other and
trust that their disclosures
will not be used against them.
They can deal with conflict productively.
They both are committed and
remain committed to their each
other's growth and development.
And it's the presence of the combination
of those things that makes a relationship
exceptional.
>> What are the key a few key takeaways
you think that can help us build
these relationships?
>> So the first key, is to recognize that
if you're going to have a relationship
like we're talking about,
you have to build the capacity to pick
up signals from two different antenna.
One antenna is what's going on for
me internally, the other antennas,
what's going on for someone else?
And the more those signals are,
the more you're attuned to those signals.
And the more they inform the choices you
make in your interaction with someone,
the more likely you are to
move towards exceptional.
I'm going to really quickly say,
there's three other keys.
One is take the risk of
allowing yourself to be known,
because the other person will be
more likely to do the same thing.
Be prepared to update your beliefs and
assumptions about what makes you
effective, particularly as a leader.
And treat every interaction
as a learning opportunity.
>> I really liked that last point.
We can learn so much and yet
we tend to get distracted by just
focusing on what we want to accomplish.
That we don't take the opportunity to
really see each opportunity as something
we can learn from.
And that goes to the first point you made
about thinking about not just what going
on for you.
But also think about what's going on for
the other person or
people you're talking to.
So, thank you for that advice, I think
that's very clear and very helpful.
David, one theme in
the classes you've taught and
in your book,
is the importance of agency and choice.
Why is this so
important in building relationships?
>> It's actually very crucial for
a couple of reasons.
One is,
think of the difference between somebody
saying they're talking about
a relationship with a friend, and
they say, I can't raise it,
I choose not to raise it.
So a world of difference.
First, I'm disempowering myself,
I'm helpless,
I'm controlled by the environment or
by the other person.
The second person, the second reason is,
I'm owning that I have agency,
I'm an active participant.
Now I may not choose to raise that but
it is a choice.
So whenever the students or
even our friends because
we drive our friends crazy.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And we come in say, no,
you're choosing not to do that.
You may want to not do it,
but it's a choice.
Now the second reason why this is
important is if I owned it, it's a choice.
It gets me into further exploration.
I choose not to raise this
point with Charlie, wonder why?
It's a Charlie, is it me?
Do I need his approval,
what am I concerned about?
And that in essence is both
a source of learning but
it's also gives you further choices.
As, for example, I may be afraid
that he's going to deny it.
All that gets me to thinking about
how I'm going to raise it and
also how I might respond.
So really owning the fact that
I have choice gives me freedom,
empowers me,
makes me an active learning participant.
>> So in essence giving yourself
permission to feel that agency allows you
so much more freedom in
the relationship and to reflect and
to motivate yourself to act.
And I can clearly see how that would help
if you simply feel like you can't do
something and you don't have control,
that's going to change
the dynamic completely.
>> Totally, totally.
>> You both advocate for
the importance of disclosure in
building stronger relationships.
Are there downsides to letting
yourself be known, being honest and
raising disengagements?
Can one of you share some best practices
that can help us disclose in a productive
and safe manner?
>> Take a shot at the first
half of that question and
then maybe ask David if he'd like to offer
up some tips around the second half.
>> Sure.
>> I would argue there's
a bigger downside for
not allowing yourself to be known for
a number of reasons.
First of all,
human beings like to make sense of things.
And the less I tell you about me,
the more opportunity I give you
to make up stories about me.
So, second of all,
if I don't tell you much about me,
you're less likely to
tell me much about you.
And to the extent that moving towards
an exceptional relationship requires
both of us to be willing to allow
ourselves to be more known,
we're moving in the wrong direction.
And third, I'd say that the downside
of not being honest and
not raising disagreements is you have
more dysfunction in the relationship.
So for best practices,
maybe David's got a couple suggestions.
>> But what I would build on what
you're saying, Carol, very nicely said,
is to indulge that matters right, there
is a risk here, there's always a risk.
So in your question,
you said are there safe ways?
There's nothing that's completely safe.
What one can do is, lower the probability
of it going south or is a risk.
And this is why we stress in the book and
we stress in the class the willingness to
take a risk because that's how you learn.
But I think one of the ways to look
at it is we talk about the 15% rule.
And I want you to think of
three concentric circles.
The inner one, smallest one is my
comfort zone where I can operate and
feel perfectly safe.
But I'm not taking any risk.
And we urge people to take a 15% risk,
which is the next ring
around this center one.
Well, I'm not sharing everything, but
I'm 15% out of my comfort zone and
a little uncomfortable.
Now, if this doesn't go well,
it's probably not a disaster.
But in all likelihood,
it's going to go well.
But it's only 15%, I don't move to
the third ring, which is a dangerous zone.
But if my 15% works well as Carol says,
you might share 15%,
that I might share another 15%.
So it's a gradual building
process where we find out what is
working with each other.
We're both taking some risks but we're
not threatening the entire relationship.
>> I like that.
So it sounds like there's
reciprocal risk taking.
And in many ways, I like the concentric
circle model because I think at least for
me, I often think about
disclosure as binary.
Either I disclose or I don't.
But what I hear you saying is that there
are choices you can make that allow you to
disclose some and then in essence
an experiment, a test to see the response.
And I like that, and it feeds back to your
previous response David about agency.
It makes you feel in control,
because sometimes disclosing you feel
like you're totally out of control.
So I like that a lot.
>> But if I could add something.
>> Sure.
>> It ties in to your point about when we
think of disclosing, we often think
of disclosing is the way I put it,
something illegal, immoral, or
in fact what we've done in the past.
And what we find in the course,
is that disclosing feelings is
the most powerful way to communicate.
>> Wow.
>> It communicates us thoughts and
feelings.
Am I feeling uncomfortable?
Am I feeling worried about where we are?
Those are often the 15% risk
that builds the relationship
because you know what's important to me.
>> And I would add there's a reason
the students call the course touchy-feely.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Because the importance of feelings in
communication is underscored and
highlighted For an entire quarter,
including the fact that they all
receive a vocabulary of feelings
as part of the syllabus and by the way,
it's an appendix in the book Content.
>> That's great, because I think a lot of
us might resonate with what you just said
about sharing feelings, but might not
have the language or the tools to do it.
So it's great that there's
a guide that can help.
So Carol, one of the first times I heard
you speak was on the topic of feedback and
I have to tell you, I was just totally
transfixed by what you were saying.
And in that conversation,
you stress the value of feedback and
said that feedback is a gift yet
most people resist giving or receiving it.
Why is that?
And what can people do to get
better about their feedback?
>> Well, this is going to tie
in a moment to the feelings
we were talking about,
but let me start by why.
>> Most people have experienced
stepping in a pile of doo doo when
they either tried to
give somebody feedback,
or somebody tried to give them feedback,
they observed a feedback exchange.
And so what happens is David likes to say
a cat never sits on a hot stove twice, but
it never sits in a cold
stove again either.
So what happens is we
don't get better by not
giving feedback,
we don't develop more skill.
And this mental model we hold,
this assumption and
belief that it's going to
harm the relationship,
something is going to go terribly awry,
gets reinforced.
It's as if we have no new
data to update it with.
So we hold these beliefs and by the way,
one of the reasons the course is so
powerful and thousands of alums for
decades have found it so transformational,
is that they got an opportunity to
experiment with giving feedback and
updating these mental
models that they hold.
And have discovered that it
actually builds relationships,
it doesn't ruin relationships.
Now, one way you're more likely to
move into experimentation is with
a little more skill.
So a big part of the book is dedicated
to some of the skills that you need
in order to be more effective
in giving feedback.
There's a central model to the course and
the book called the net.
And that's a very specific way of
giving somebody feedback that's
both behaviorally specific, and
includes the reaction of other
person's behaviors,
your reactions to their behaviors.
So for example, my husband comes
home this is now many years ago,
the stories in the book.
Many years ago, he comes home
from a long day in the valley.
He's been working very hard, he collapses
in the chair in the front room and
grabs the newspaper.
I hear him,
I come running out of the bathroom.
And I start talking, my God, you're home.
Thank God blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
And he does not raise his
eyes from his newspaper.
And the only thing he responds with is.
Now that's the behavior,
no eye contact and grunk.
My reaction is I feel dismissed and
I don't feel heard and
I feel hurt, but
appears the problem in an exchange
between two people there
are three realities.
There's reality number one,
what's going on for Andy.
Reality number number two,
the behavior he's engaging in.
The only reality that's
known to both of us.
And there's reality number three,
which is what's happening for me.
And we talk about a metaphorical
net between what's going on for
him, his reality number one and
the other two.
So I don't know what's going on for
him, but what I do when I don't
understand the concept of the net is
I say, you're not listening to me.
Well, that assumes that I'm in his head.
And I know and I don't.
You're not listening to me is
over the net and it gets worse.
I feel that you don't care.
First of all, is not a feeling.
And second of all is an attribution,
it's imputing a motive.
I don't know whether he cares or
not, unless he says I don't care.
So until I learned to say,
when you make no eye contact and
the only thing I get is a grunt,
I don't feel heard.
And I feel hurt and dismissed.
And I'm telling you this because it
makes me less inclined to want to be
there for you.
That's the complete package of a piece of
feedback that's entirely on my side of
the net.
And it's likely to make him
less defensive and saying,
I feel that you're not sensitive or I feel
that you don't care because by the way,
that's incredibly unfair.
He's the most sensitive man on the planet.
>> [LAUGH] If I could add a little
bit to that which is a great
description, is we also say
around the GSB [COUGH] And
this is part of the notion is
that feedback is a gift, and
it takes two to no one
As Andy needs Carol to know,
nd he needs to know
the effect of his behavior.
If we don't know the effect of our
behavior, we're shooting in the dark, and
you don't hit the target
when you're shooting.
So that's why feedback is a gift when it's
given with the intention to help each
other to help the other and
to help the relationship.
>> And if we go back to your question
about receiving feedback by the way if you
want others to be better givers then it
behooves you to become a better receiver.
>> Sure.
>> Date we say it's a gift and by the way
sometimes it's wrapped in a really ugly
wrapping really hard to tell
there's even a gift right.
But if you can respond to a piece of
feedback even if its over the net because
the person didn't read the book, and
they don't know what they're doing.
You can respond with respond
with curiosity and inquiry.
Hah, what is it that I have done, and
what exactly is the result of that?
How is that making you feel?
You can push them back over the net.
>> Wow, well thank you both for
giving us the gift of insight
into how to give better feedback.
From my perspective what I
hear you talking about is,
it's about the approach you take.
It's about understanding all parties
involved in what information
they have access to and
taking time to be deliberate and
thoughtful in giving feedback is critical.
So thank you for that and I for
one have received many gifts that did not
appear to be gifts at first, but
in hindsight they certainly were.
I'm curious to get your suggestions for
how we can better connect and
develop our relationships now that so
much of our communication is virtual.
Do you have some suggestions for us?
>> Yeah, well, first of all, everything
that we've been talking about and
everything that's in the book,
I think is something to consider
doubling down during this time.
So, the fact is that it's,
I think we've become much more
transactional as a result of the pandemic,
and much more task oriented,
especially in business at
the expense of relationships.
So we have a lot of contact maybe but
not a whole lot of connection and
if we want more connection.
Then we've got to make a little
bit of time to ask each other how
you really do what's really going on.
I have a CEO that's in my program
in my leaders in tech program
right now who starts every
meeting by having every member
of his team start with a two
minute if you really knew me.
And then he times them in for two minutes
they have to complete that phrase.
>> That distinction between contact and
connection,
opened up so many doors for me.
I've really been struggling, because I'm
thinking to myself, I'm talking to so
many people, and teaching so many people,
and yet I don't feel the same connection.
Than I used to, and thank you for
helping make that distinction.
So we have to take the time to actually
connect it doesn't mean that we're looking
at faces on a screen, you actually
have to connect with those faces.
Thank you.
Before we end, I'd like to ask
you the same three questions.
I asked everyone who joins
me are you guys up for that?
>> Yeah, sounds good.
>> Yeah.
>> Excellent.
So Carol, if you were to capture the best
communication advice you ever received
as a five to seven word presentation,
slide title, what would it be?
>> Chairman whether this really
comes down to five words.
>> It's okay you can have a few extra.
Interpersonal success depends on who
you're talking to, and for what purpose.
>> Okay, that's a little extra, but
we're going to let it slide
because it's really insightful.
Tell me a little bit more.
>> So, one of the biggest mistakes people
make is they think one size fits all.
One of the most important things
students learn in touchy feely
is the exact opposite, which is why we
were going to write five easy steps
to be more interpersonally effective.
The fact is,
connecting with someone else is nuanced.
It's idiosyncratic to that
particular relationship.
What works for you and
me Matt to connect more deeply may or
may not be what works for
David and me and so
to the extent that I want to be
effective in connecting with you.
I've got to take you and me in our
relationship into consideration in
the context of the relationship,
are we work colleagues?
Are we friends?
And so I think that's kind of
what's underneath the seven word or
at nine words or
however many words I have.
>> Great.
Well, Carol, it is a true pleasure to
call to have you as a work colleague and
a friend.
So thank you.
Who is a communicator that you admire and
why?
>> I'm going to pick two people I can-
>> Sure.
>> First person is a therapist
I had many years ago.
And Lawrence was so effective because.
I sense that she really
wanted to get to know me.
One thing she was very honest and
she pulled no punches,
but she was also aware of
as a therapist would say.
When their shit gets in the way, and
when she was hooked by something I say,
she would stop and
say "oop that's me, I'm sorry and
it was just wonderful.
The other person I'm going to
name actually is Carol.
And we've tested the communication now for
many many years but
over the last 3.5 years I'm
going to say as to Carol.
Carol why I pick you is most of
the time you're clean in terms
of what you say, and
second when you're not I can raise it and
I rarely experience you getting
defensive or explain yourself.
But you really do live with a notion
that feedback is a gift and
you're doing something and
we clean it up right away.
And I find after we have cleaned it up,
I feel closer to you.
It is built the relationship.
So I mean that and I have really valued
you as a co author and
as a very close friend.
>> Thank you David.
I'm really touched and right back at
you in every regard, so who do I admire?
The first person that sprang to mind for
me that's obviously
famous is Barack Obama.
And the reason obviously,
he's a great orator and he's very,
his very succinct and articulate and
just a pleasure to listen to.
But the reason he came to mind for me was
two and I've had the immense privilege and
pleasure of meeting him in person,
>> Wow.
>> Is that what you see
is what you get and
of course he's got his public persona and
but
I feel incredibly drawn to him.
And the reason I feel drawn to him is
he's not afraid to show his emotions.
He's not afraid to talk
about how he's feeling.
He has conviction and strength, but
also of vulnerability in
a willingness to be wrong.
That is inspiring.
>> I totally agree I've had the great
fortune not to meet him but
I met one of his speech writers who
echoes everything that you just said.
So thank you both for sharing that.
So David, what are the first
three ingredients that go into
a successful communication
recipe from your perspective?
>> Well I'm Carol stole my thunder but
that's
>> No am sorry [LAUGH]
>> No it's wonderful because I'm going to
build it it's really very important.
We sometimes communicate
to get the task done but
I want to talk about the interplay
between communication and relationships.
First, first thing is that love
the three that you asked for
is I have to take account
of this relationship and
not treat relationships
as a general statement.
>> What is the other words
the other person right now,
what do they need, what do I need
how robust is our relationship.
So that's the first private I
take how the relationship then I
need to take account of the fact
that in most of my conversations,
I want to communicate in order
to build this relationship.
And this isn't just with intimate
people that I have, but I find, for
example, when I go to the store,
I do the shopping for the household.
>> I like to have a more
personal relationship,
even with the clerk and
could I communicate in
a way that shows that person I
see that person as an individual?
Solely of two minute interaction.
So I want to see communication as
a way to build the relationship.
And the third one is,
if I have done that and
I have built a strong relationship,
I can communicate in so many more ways.
I can share so much more about myself.
I can even make more
mistakes because I know
we have the foundation to recover from it.
So for me the communication has to be
closely tied with the relationship
they're intertwined and
they have to be seen together.
>> Very powerful and
important point that communication
happens within a relationship.
And I like how you layer that description
where you start with appreciating
the relationship building
the relationship and
that frees you to have a variety of
different types of communication.
>> Thank you both your insights and
ideas have been incredibly helpful.
To my mind, they boil down to agency,
introspection and connection,
and especially balancing out
both thoughts and feelings.
[MUSIC]
I believe everyone who has listened in can
see why the class you helped build and
taught for so
many years has been so successful.
And speaking of success,
I wish you much of it with your new book.
All the best.
Thank you for listening to Think Fast
Talk Smart the podcast is a production of
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
To learn more, go to gsb.stanford.edu.
Please download other episodes
wherever you find your path.
[MUSIC]